la douleur dernièrement c'est devenu une
vieille connaissance
des genres qui vient quand on est
toujours blessé par la même personne
[Musique]
ps tu rêves de seattle depuis le jour où
je t'ai rencontrée s'il était vraiment
amoureux ils te suivrai en fait j'espère
est qu'on aille vivre allons dans la fin
de ses études comment j'ai testé d'abord
tout ça
il n'y a que dans ses rares moments il
me serre contre lui me fait des
promesses qu'ils semblent incapables de
tenir
que la douleur disparaît assez 1
c'est tout
sb
ce sera tout
les relations de couple c'est compliqué
tu as un super emploi à seattle mais moi
j'ai rien de tout ça mais tu m'as - ok
mais c'est passé tim avoir te suffit pas
c'est ton problème mais tu meures
tiendra plus
je vais pas abandonner si apple pourtant
si toi tu m'abandonnes
au carré
tu agit toujours comme ça si sa botte
chaque bon moment qu'on passe ensemble
et non si j'avais voulu faire ça je
t'aurais parler du numéro de ce gars
dans tes contacts c'est pas toi tu sois
dire qu'ils tombent et d'amis qui peut
pas seulement être ton ami ok
comment je puisse avoir tiré non
ça suffit aux aliments être à toi quand
tu fis
je voulais te dire depuis longtemps
yak avec toi que subit un test